[Music]
four-time Super Bowl champ two-time
Super Bowl MVP class of 1989 in Canton
Ohio one of the tops in our profession
talking about football over there at Fox
and man oh man does this movie look
hilarious father figures in theaters
Friday December 22nd where this man
plays himself
Terry brats are up Terry Brad you know
it's hard telling me well you've done it
before and Smokey and the Bandit - right
and you play your side did Cannonball
Run ok for you yourself a Cannonball Run
is well know I was a SWAT guy from
Houston yeah cannonball - I was me yes
I'm Hooper were you yourself probably
yeah yeah yeah no Hooper's SWAT okay and
then what was the one with the Mel
Tillis Cannonball Run with Mel Tillis
manda - it was it was you and Klecko
right Joe Greene Mean Joe Greene yeah
that's stupid that when did you first
get into who's the first to knock on
your door when your your you're playing
for mr. Rooney Chuck no Chuck no I don't
know if he's probably ever seen it we
ever saw moving in his life I doubt it
right so who knocked on your door Terry
and say hey let's put you in movies we
had done we had played Super Bowl 10
against Cowboys in the night before NBC
back they would have a Super Bowl
special yeah and NBC had they did all
these you know little skits Burt
Reynolds own and Burt Reynolds did a
dumb skit about me hmm
I was watching and it was I mean it was
good and but Steeler fans were so upset
with Burke's portrayal of me that the
report was 25,000 letters come flying
into his publicist who was David Gershon
s'en so bertson's David gursha
I was open up out here singing at the
Palomino club my first gig was at the
Palomino club you might meet or you were
touring a singing tour yeah singing to
her okay so I had a guy I had a country
album out yeah and a hit song on it and
so David
Burt Reynolds found out and sent David
Gerson out and presented me with the
horseshoe-shaped carnations and a big
letter of apology and what I please come
to the set of Hooper the next morning he
wants to meet me in person and I had to
be in Albuquerque for another show so I
went out early that morning and Bert
couldn't apologized enough and he got
how I need him the director and on the
top of the truck he said we got to put
him in this movie find something for him
in this movie and they wrote me in the
movie right there on the truck I'm a set
on the yes and so I came back after
about three weeks and I shot this little
scene and that movie career was born
Scott started then I did smoke in van de
tooth and Cannonball Run which was my
first really big role and then and then
from there I went to I took I took some
time off like 18 years to find myself
sure and then I got offered the role in
failure to launch and I turned it down
you did and then they should called
again and I turned it down again they
called the third time and the director
said if I grab an actress and a camera
and come to your ranch you read for me
on Cameron with the actress I said
listen I get out of church at 12:30 from
1:00 till 2:00 I'll let that's it
because I'm really not interested that's
the window and so they'd showed up let
them in they set the camera he made the
script and I read for failure to launch
six weeks later I got the I got the part
so the the actress who came to ranch
wasn't Kathy Bates no no no no Kathy
Bates does not go to some Ding Dongs
[Laughter]
it's a good question thank you though so
is McConaughey the one who kept on
hammering we got it was Tom day the
director okay and I have to feel that
that part was turned down because of
money
I think it was Robert Duvall I'm a
little bit bigger because Robert get
this get this
yeah my first trip to Hollywood was in
1971 and I was looking for a movie agent
and I double dated that night to paper
moon remember the paper Ryan O'Neal's
opponent I date a double date that night
with Robert Duvall yeah okay I'm gonna
bite on this one no how did how did how
did you and Robert Duvall wind up double
dating same agent okay same agent put us
together yeah Duvall what was he a
Steeler fan or something like the Nana
I don't think so at all I don't think so
this is like pre Immaculate reception oh
this really thing no I don't know what I
was thinking thinking I could be in
movies but you know they say nowadays
you know I watched Jerry Maguire the
other day and I got the cush cush sure
and I'm listening to the agent that's
the comedian now he's anymore yeah yeah
funny guy yeah him say hey look when I
were going don't he's there writing his
coffee and he goes yeah we're global
movies so stupid because his father was
upset because what we want him to go
number one in Denver or whatever San
Diego yeah so it's it's kind of funny
really
yeah the moody thing just well you've
always been I try it all you've always
been in that pop culture range and
certainly before Oh seriously before
before NFL players really did that quite
a bit I mean obviously get Liam if you
want to start like Gifford might have
been the first Sam Huff might have been
the first right types of guys right and
then suddenly in the semis that might
get a little bit more than that
you were sitting like on The Tonight
Show set with Tony Orlando right I did
with Carson The Tonight Show in the 70s
I was on Leno I was on with Jay Leno 54
times
fifty-four times I mean did you talk
football once with him he has no I'm
doing rod show Monday yeah we think
about cars he doesn't know anything he
has no clue
are you selling that show throw him
curve balls about football it wouldn't
be in the script that screw is script up
ya know the teams that are in Los
Angeles guarantee you right now right
now right now throw a dart board a dart
at the board and figure the remember
back no not at all fine no of course no
no I'm totally fine I saw Leno do
stand-up when I was at the University of
Michigan in the mid 80s to this day some
of the funniest standup that I have ever
ever seen I've seen him I wonder lien I
saw him in at the wind star casino mm-hm
I heard he was coming into Vacaville
Oklahoma because now everybody does
these you know casinos all there's
thousands of them right and that's how
all these old-timers stay busy yeah they
all they get them in there to get the
ambulance out front to get the oxygen
loaded up sure I saw him at a casino win
star in fact Ville Oklahoma I tell you
brilliant oh yeah I'm with screaming fun
as you ever try stand-up Terry I did I
did on The Tonight Show
it was horrible come on now I did so I
asked him one night I said when they
call me I do the show I said hey tell
Jay I just want to do like two minutes
of stand-up so AJ said yeah so man I'm
home and I'm right and I'm writing and
then I got a buddy of mine yeah Jon max
that works for Lynn oh so I call him up
I said here
here's system jokes I got he goes well
try this and do that and so I hope yeah
oh that's fun yours is much funny so I
got these jokes from John Beck's yeah
and I put them all together and I got
them out and so there they are a study
study study study I go over and work on
telling my wife hey here I was doing
this I don't think say my job I go out
there in front of Terry and then I said
a second and then I thought okay then
then I did it then I screwed up the
third one I turn around to look for rim
yeah encouragement man and he's going
you know I had to do it and it wasn't
funny but but I was laughing so hard the
fact the viewers laughing listen I think
that and that's what works obviously
well and that's one obviously what works
for you on the air with what you do with
Fox and have done for sometimes you're
yourself and you are who you are and and
that's it you just put it out there and
that's what people can relate let's take
a break come back in 60 seconds we'll
talk a little bit of father figures and
then I do want to hit you on some
football stuff
okay guys do it cuz we got five weeks to
go in the National I know it's down
there and it is in the NFC is so wide
open it's ridiculous I have not seen any
advocacy not really rich okay folks hang
on that's Terry Bradshaw back in 60
seconds here in the Rich Eisen show
[Music]
really had
until you my gospel out this is you yeah
the brackets to play the hits of years I
never run
real
for me John Denver like if you don't
mind me saying don't mean to be
disrespectful but actually I've been
I've been doing shows with the Isaacs
I'm a gospel guy sure and I've done two
gospel albums and gospel is really where
I love to do so I went to the Ryman
Auditorium last year and saying with the
Isaacs as my backup and I did a song
Kevin remember the song now anyway at
the Ryman o for the Eagles okay cause a
Glenn Frey it passed away yes and I'm a
huge Eagles fan huge and so I did this
the Eagles song and at the Ryman and
this place is going crazy and there's
nothing like that rich whether you're
good or not to hear this this applause
in this historic it was a church the
Ryman where all the you know the Grand
Ole Opry that's where it started right
there all the greats and then I went
back last month and saying at the end in
honor of Glen Campbell yeah and I did
the big Opry the big one in Nashville so
I've done it twice a both times with the
Isaacs don't say hello the Isaac I gotta
tell you and we're actually gonna go on
tour and April solved up to her with him
a little bit in April my first 45 I'm 45
nobody knows what that is the first 45
of my life
that I wore out was Rhinestone Cowboy
Wow wore it out I followed going
Campbell I play golf with going Campbell
I I want to sing like Glen Campbell
which I could play like I mean the guy
is just amazing and then the last album
was just heartbreaking the last one just
the whole story the Alzheimer's that he
got and finally took his life yeah Terry
Oh Terry Bradshaw here on the Rich Eisen
show well we'll talk about your movie
father figures in a second but I will
use you mentioning the Eagles rock band
as the
segue to talk some football with you
this did I said going to break that I
think the NFC is is wide open as it's
been in some time and you basically you
went Lee Corso on me in a way saying not
so fast Connelly course of me they're
going a break
is it the Eagles that you think is yeah
that's a dominant team dominant at the
Vikings you see the Saints with that run
I attack a defense you see I mean I
could go down the list here in Los
Angeles with that offense you can look
at Seattle the teams are the teams are
the Eagles Seattle still not as much now
they should all them probably down the
Rams out here in Los Angeles the Rams
are I thought the win last week against
New Orleans was huge for them because
they had played the Vikings last week
and lost great great team they had lost
at home to Seattle a great team at that
I'm not a great team but a really good
team sure two really good defenses and
then the Saints were coming in as a
really good defense shockingly in the
NFL and they beat them at home and but
the Eagles have stood out all year they
have not faltered they've had a couple
of close games but they have been solid
steady their defense is phenomenal they
get great rotation in their in their
defense fresh Wentz obviously more
unlikely could be in a second year guy
the MVP of the league so I see that see
Atlanta probably finding their stride
because I've been one that said all year
long nothing wrong with Atlanta hmm you
get your ass handed to you had two
leading 28 to 3 with 17 minutes left in
a Super Bowl I'm telling you you don't
get over that that last that lingers
that is that is not something you pass
off because you have just your defining
moment as a football player in the NFL
just went out the window
you're defined alright you gave up what
20 whatever's 25 yeah unanswered points
and loss so but they are coming on the
South Carolina Cam Newton the passing
games not is no good and and now we're
seeing the Saints team playing good
defense not throwing throwing like we
are accustomed to see them throw with
Drew Brees so when it's a tappa
it's not when it's all said and done the
so you think the Eagles are just Kyu I
miss this mind just okay just hang your
hat on it and go with it I think it I
think it'll come down to Minneapolis and
Philly
okay that's my guess and then over in
the AFC it's obviously newing right then
that week 15 game in Pittsburgh is gonna
be such a a monster one what is your
relationship with Big Ben I know nothing
at all why would that be well I don't
live there okay well I mean but you said
there's texting there's phones they're
not like you don't know okay
I don't do that a text but not okay but
I have yeah I'm 69 what's he thirty five
or six I mean there's okay I I had my
you know I made a few remarks about Ben
when he first came out about self the
motorbike then had the crash and I
didn't know him at all and I said it
tongue-in-cheek and had fun with it
but he didn't know me and I didn't know
him and the reporters all came to me and
said hey telling me about this motorbike
I give me that camera I did it mm-hm
and then so that kind of got us off to
the to the wrong foot and then he had
the problems early in his career I
having two daughters was did not
hesitate to let him know how I feel
about that so that's that's been it I've
gone up to him and when we did the game
I've gone up to him say hey Ben and
he'll mr. Bradshaw and I'm like mr.
Bratz okay I get it
and then we our producers wanted me to
sit out with him when they played in the
Super Bowl against Green Bay so we set
in there and I did all the talking it
was to patch things up but I did the
talking how were your family Pittsburgh
Steeler family and so forth and there
wasn't much from him at all on that and
then he went outside and the reporters
were waiting and he said well Terry
realizes I didn't have all my facts
straight this one okay so that's that's
it so that's that that's that no no real
harm
no no harm done no ill feelings totally
pull for him no problem
Owens all the records I'm so past stuff
like that sure and then when
all comes down to it he is part of the
same draft class as Phillip yep and he
live in Eli and now we're seeing what's
playing out with all these guys where
Big Ben has got another Super Bowl
chance Phillip is trying to get back in
the playoff right and we saw what went
down with Eli that's right what do you
think of this situation with Eli and the
Giants rich I'm disappointed in what's
happened
had it been with a coach I respect that
would be one thing have Tom Coughlin
still been there I would look at it
differently but this guy that's coaching
them I don't know why he did that I
understand the business look take it you
gotta go with it right it comes to an
end asked his brother all very few can
retire like Dan Marino and John Elway
Elway had it perfect Super Bowl wins
sell-off that's how you do it Eli has
earned the right with the two Super Bowl
victories two two MVPs and the amazing
games that he played in those Super
Bowls because that's what we're measured
by when I measured by yards and
touchdowns
we're measured by championships he has
earned the right I think to go out and
in a classy way but there is a cruelness
about this league that we as players
have to understand when we no longer
can't perform all right when we don't
produce then that's when we better start
we better start looking over our
shoulder we better pack it up because if
that is the bottom line and I feel bad
for you lie I saw him in the locker room
I saw how emotionally was broke my heart
be honest with you but it's the coach
that I Geno Smith are you kidding me
Geno Smith yeah I know that cuz I
thought they were gonna go at the young
kid Davis Webb just to see what he's got
with three division opponents coming
into their house let's see what he's got
if you want to see what anybody's got
you don't look to Gino Smith he failed
in New York yet what 12 and 18 record
there something like that he had a
losing record I didn't like
coming out of college I didn't like him
with the Jets I haven't seen him play in
a long time
all I know is he'll be healthy and this
game against the Raiders and he does
provide the ability to get out of
problems and that is something Eli could
never do and maybe McAdoo is saying well
our offensive line is so poor in a
receiver so poor that maybe we can we
can salvage something with with Geno
Smith playing and that's the only reason
but I just it's sad it's just it's sad
that the Mannings are such a classy
bunch of folks sure you know it just
said so before I let you go I'm not
leaving no well I gotta leave but you
know our show is coming to an end it's
know I got it but I want you back yeah
okay nobody ever calls me and and I'm
wondering why I'm not on the Rich Eisen
show so why'd father figures why do you
want to play yourself I know it's a
helluva game they called me and I when I
got the movie part they were having a
hard time figuring out who what role
they wanted a professional quarterback
that won Super Bowls but they couldn't
figure out who they wanted me to be and
I said well that's easy I'll just be me
mm-hmm and they said oh you're okay with
that they were worried that I wouldn't
be I said absolutely and so that's how
that happened you like to have you never
seen smoke do not see me that's right
season two premieres in January 2018
also with you William Shatner Henry
Winkler George Foreman awesome man Jeff
died great comedian that's right huh of
course you hunts down Fox every Sunday
actually would you stay for the rest of
the show would you do that yeah okay
yeah it's just a few more men
because our funnier died pitch Friday
we've got a where we we throw out a
topic and then listeners call in or they
write in some jokes and then we just
joke yeah jokes
oh good just like it
like a late-night chef we can do that
very good Terry Bradshaw's not going
anywhere which is not tense all right
here folks he's right there
he's got a bug on me a chair I'm like
your co-host now all right tell you my
wife just texted me here in this
conversation Susie Schuster chimes in
saying quote he was great on Modern
Family she's loved you on Modern Family
thank you what's her name
Susie thanks Susie you got it now Ed
O'Neill my buddy was I played with him
too hot by Chuck no I know my rookie
year he was a linebacker and I've known
that I did what was a married with
children married with children twice
with him and all we did was talk
football
anyway I shot this show the other day
it's all we did was talk football the
whole time and I said ed do you remember
when you got cut by Pittsburgh yes I
said my rookie year he said that he told
a story that his dad drove in the
training camp out there in Pennsylvania
and he looked around he basically said
to him as he dropped him off said you
have no show
wait on me yeah and it was Chuck Noel's
first ever training camp yeah
Neal was one of the final cuts pretty
cool in that and then what's worth
nowadays got enough money that he could
buy a part yeah but do you remember ed
when you when you absolutely do yeah
okay absolutely I'm absolutely remember
him it was a nutty was a neat guy really
neat that's funny
that's really funny that show is so
great man they got one more year with
modern modern family one more year now
he has been so fortunate because both of
the shows he's done have all gone over
ten years you know what the residuals
you don't add that up jack that's some
serious cash what was that what was the
last residual check you got from smoking
the Bandit to
you get those still probably like a
dollar sixteen CSI Miami one okay much
98 cents there you go it's not but it's
the gram amount I do suck at Caruso I'm
sure if mom get 98 cent his residuals
must be through the roof oh it's gotta
be Millions
my daughter wrote a song she made three
hundred fifty thousand dollars we won
fast 30 150 thousand he had bad back she
had to go get a mattress she said dad I
gotta go get a mattress I'll call you
from the mattress store get to the
mattress store she called me oh I got a
bat mattress two thousand dollars and I
got the store manager here and he said
he'll take your credit card over the
phone we've got our pitch Friday Funny
or Die has an app teri call right hitch
okay we're there they have all of these
concepts threads as the kids will call
it and then people write in some funny
lines from them and then the best jokes
get paid and we are giving away a
subscription to our viewers and
listeners who chime in with the best
joke based on the thread that we throw
out that week so as we do okay so the
pitch rich Friday thread from the Funny
or Die this week is give us the best way
that Eli Manning is going to get his
revenge on the Giants the best way okay
so here we go ways of the Eli Manning
I've got them for you said you were the
Ed McMahon
yeah you are
number five number five withdraw his
LinkedIn endorsement of Ben McAdoo for
coaching that's number four number four
sneak up behind Geno before the first
snap wearing an item polygraph he's the
one who busted his job Tara got it
number three lock been McAdoo in a room
with Mike Francesa I think French that
so would definitely take him out number
two steel Ben McAdoo's hair gel not an
attractive guy gets his revenge on the
Giants applies for the soon-to-be vacant
head coaching job that one let's go you
that that joke was written by I always
like giving the credit here of course I
can't get my phone David McLaughlin of
New York City wrote that look and then
the listener viewer submission mystery
ed Marty Ryan direct messages what you
are your information cuz you just got
yourself a subscription to pitch host
SNL with musical guest Ben McAdoo doing
his rendition of my way there you go
you win yourself a subscription gonna be
next year singing that somewhere else
uh-huh oh I think so it's just crazy
it's nuts it is nutty yeah where do you
think he loves gonna be minutes later if
I were a needle I shoe and this happened
to me yes then I got two years left on
my contract I'd go in say hey look I
said you're obviously rebuilding and and
they like use the phrase we're going
indirect different directions other very
very famous I would then say move me
move me and to where tell you where I'm
thinking I think everybody says
Jacksonville correct yes cuz coffin
talkin I got a running game they got a
heck of a defense and at his age now
protect him he's smart he's cool he's
under poised and everything I think he'd
be perfect in Jeff that's a first place
I think of Miss Jacksonville and then
other people have said Denver and I'm
not sure that that would happen I don't
know if he would go to where Peyton what
I wouldn't because it's a no-win
situation yeah my brother out of college
follow me to Louisiana Tech and I told
him don't go to Louisiana Tech don't
don't follow me and he got there he was
gone to Utah State
wherever that is I think Utah right
father figures in theatres Friday
theaters Friday December 22nd where you
play yourself
Owen Wilson and Ed Helms your kids do
some of the best acting I've ever done
by the way we saw the clip oh that's
just a snippet look and and and anybody
will tell you you've grown since Hooper
you've grown actor you've grown as an
actor oh yeah
only thing I missed was singing the
theme song to the movie that's my next
thing well that'll be another one yes
that's another one for you can you play
Jerry Reed going to break man come on
now Smokey and the Bandit to star Terry
Bradshaw here I want to thank again
Andrew Siciliano for taking care of our
number one Rhys Davis it's you Terry
Bradshaw you were welcome here any time
tell me everybody hello at Fox next week
Steve Mariucci Denis Leary in studio Jim
Belushi and studio Morgan Freeman in
studio Morgan Freeman I was with Morgan
Freeman about three months ago awesome
dude
all right a great weekend everybody
for more Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel - 39 on DirecTV or download the
Rich Eisen show app